mais là mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir en
direct avec nous pour ce journal
d'antenne 2 le premier ministre monsieur
raymond barre ce premier ministre je
vous remercie d'être avec nous en cette
fin de semaine vous êtes décidément le
personnage central de la scène publique
française d'abord et je le rappelle il
ya six mois jour pour jour vous preniez
la direction de ce gouvernement
il y as malgré votre peu de goût pour
les affaires politiques ou pour une
certaine politique la situation dans la
majorité et les attaques d'une partie de
l'opposition
il y a et c'est important la baisse en
janvier des prix industriels pour la
première fois depuis quatre ans et une
inflation limitée à 0 3%
nous l'avons expliqué hier soir il ya
une telle différence entre l' indice de
la cgt 0.9 et votre indice de l'insee
0,3 que la cgt la cfdt parle de trucage
ou de manipulation que monsieur michel
rocard compare votre indice à un cachet
d'aspirine qui ne guérira pas la fièvre
alors monsieur le premier ministre deux
mois de suite 0.3 annonce-t-il pour
autant de bons indices d'aussi bons
indices en février en mars son avril
alors que les tarifs publics ne seront
plus bloquée permettez-moi de vous
rappeler quelle est l'inspiration de la
politique que mène le gouvernement en
matière de prix en septembre 1976 nous
avions en france un taux d'inflation en
tendance annuelle de l'ordre de 12 à 13%
il fallait casser un mouvement
psychologique qui entraînait un
emballement à la hausse des prix
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement a décidé un gel des prix
rappelez-vous ce qu'on a dit à ce
moment-là le gel va échouer
et lorsqu'au mois de novembre lundi ça a
été de 0,8 alors que nous avions fait la
hausse du prix de l'essence qui était
absolument nécessaire
on a dit c'est un échec de la politique
de gel des prix en décembre nous avons
eu 1 à 10
de 0,3 c'était la preuve que les
comportements changent et et que le gel
des prix était respecté c'est
l'explication de l' indice de dessins et
nous avons ainsi réussi à calmer les
anticipations de prix au mois de janvier
le gel des prix s'est arrêté et le
gouvernement a mis en place une baisse
de la taxe à la valeur ajoutée qui
devait normalement entraîné une
diminution des prix industriels
tout le monde a dit c'est un gaspillage
pourquoi diminuer la tva d'ailleurs vous
verrez ce lavage et nous avons eu un
indice de 0,3 qui s'explique par un seul
fait c'est la discipline des français
qui ont appliqué la baisse de la tva
il n'y a pas de trucage ce n'est pas le
gouvernement qui fait lundi
c'est l'institut national de la
statistique et des études économiques
et maintenant vous demande de dominici
vous allez faire preuve d'autant de
rigueur après les municipales avant que
je vous parle de la rigueur
je voudrais vous dire ceci sur les prix
on oublie un peu trop que si j'avais
voulu mener une politique de prix
électoral est artificielle j'aurais
bloquer les prix pour 18 mois c'est à
dire jusqu'au 1er avril 1978
cela aurait été confortable pour moi
pour le gouvernement mais cela aurait
été stupide car cela ne sert à rien de
bloquer les prix il faut revenir à une
politique des prix et à une évolution
des prix qui ne soit pas artificiel
alors tant monsieur rocard dit que c'est
un cachet d'aspirine
je pense qu'il est assez avertis pour
savoir qu'il faut parfois prendre
certaines mesures pour briser les
emballements psychologique en matière
d'inflation
mais ce que nous allons faire maintenant
c'est une politique des prix qui repose
sur des facteurs économiques
c'est-à-dire sur une politique du crédit
qui est rigoureux
je signale qu'à la fin de 1976 la masse
monétaire et moyennes paiement augmenté
au taux de 24 à 25 % l'an au dernier
trimestre 2009 176 autant de 12%
le budget est gérée de façon rigoureuse
et nous maintiendrons la politique des
rémunérations qui se fixe sur le strict
de maintien du pouvoir d'achat et je
crois que de cette façon nous aurons une
modération des prix en 1977 alors vous
me posez une question importante
monsieur elkabbach
comment évolueront les indices au cours
des prochains mois je ne suis pas
prophète
ce que je peux dire c'est que nous
prouverons au certainement un mois ou
l'autre avoir des indices plus élevé que
0,3 mais il ne faudra pas considéré pour
cela que l'inflation repart
si nous avons des indices plus élevées
c'est parce qu'il y aura des facteurs
qui expliquent ce phénomène par exemple
les entreprises ont maintenant la
liberté de prix mais assortis de
contrats de modération elles
augmenteront leurs prix
et puis aussi déprise agricole et enfin
les prix des produits importés
ce que je demande aux françaises et aux
français c'est de considérer non pas des
indices mensuelle mais de considérer la
tendance et je peux vous dire que la
tendance au cours de l'année 1977 sera à
une modération sensible de la hausse des
prix par rapport au taux d'inflation que
nous connaissions il ya six mois quand
je suis devenu premier ministre
c'est à dire 12 % mais vous ne donnez
pas une évaluation je ne peux pas à quoi
sert donner une évaluation et lundi
dernier j'ai entendu au matin sur un
poste périphériques
un commentateur non je ne sais pas quel
est son nom et il paraît que c'est un
augure
il y est toujours informé avant les
autres canon cclat hausse des prix
serait de 0,5 à 0,6 pour cent et à
partir de ce moment là j'ai senti dans
certains milieux une agitation
rumeur qui disait vous voyez tout ce que
le gouvernement fait ça n'a aucun
intérêt c'est le chèque
eh bien voyez ce qui s'est passé même ce
point il sait ce que c'est pourtant une
victoire si ces résultats s'accompagnent
d'une extrême sensibilité du franc et
notre part d'un déficit du commerce
extérieur bien alors sur ces deux sujets
ils sont très importants dois vous dire
ceci
en ce qui concerne le franc nous avons
vu non pas une crise du franc nous avons
eu pendant deux ou trois jours à léger
glissement du franc de 4 francs 97 pour
un dollar à 4 francs 99 alors on entendu
partout dire mais c'est une fille c'est
une crise du franc aujourd'hui par
rapport à toutes les devises le franc
et quand les français devront retrouver
la confiance
est ce que mes joueurs ont fait ce n'est
pas les français monsieur elkabbach qui
ont perdu la confiance et qui ont besoin
de la retrouver
c'est le petit groupe
des commentateurs inspiré ma dire qu'on
vise encore il faut raisonner non
voilées journal il se pose y en a
certains qui ont fait très bon article
qui ont très bien expliquer la chose il
y en a d'autres et pas seulement les
journalistes qui sont tout à fait
désireux de voir échouer la politique du
gouvernement pour des raisons diverses
mais ce n'est pas je crois à l'égard
d'une politique qui concerne l'intérêt
du pays
une attitude qui soit très défendable
mais ce qu'on est en train aussi de voir
le problème s'est déplacé vers l'emploi
je sais que j'en parlerai bientôt mais
j'aimerais que nous donner une certaine
indications il y a un problème d'emploi
pas seulement en france mais dans tous
les pays industrialisés et ceci est la
conséquence de l'inflation nous avons
subi cet emploi est menacé mais il est
menacé à la fois par l'inflation nous
avons connue et par l'adaptation de nos
entreprises aux nouvelles conditions de
l'échangé international mais je crois
que nous sommes en mesure de surmonter
ses problèmes à condition que nous
rétablissions nos équilibres
il ya une situation difficile c'est
celle des jeunes
il y à une autre situation préoccupante
c'est celle des cadres eh bien le
gouvernement s'en occupe déjà et
continuera à s'en occuper avec le plan
de la sidérurgie que vous présentait il
ya quelques jours vous mentez qu'il n'y
aura plus en quelque sorte d'abonnés aux
aides de l'état et vous disiez souvent
qu'il fallait s'attaquer vraiment aux
racines de l'inflation alors quels sont
pour vous les secteurs prioritaires et
ce que vous pouvez vraiment agir dans
une période de passion électorale il ne
faut pas se demander si l'on doit agir
en fonction de l'absence d'élections ou
de la proximité d'élections n'est pas ce
souci aucun aucun souci de ce genre il
ya des problèmes qui se posent à la
france
le président de la république m'a nommé
premier ministre pour traiter ce
problème le gouvernement m'apporte en la
matière un concours dévoué et nous nous
efforçons de traiter les problèmes
qu'est ce qu'il faut à la france il faut
des industries qui soit solide
qu'ils soient compétitives qui soit en
mesure non seulement de produire mais
aussi d'exporter et de garantir un
emploi stable
c'est notre objectif et nous avons
commencé par traiter le dossier de la
sidérurgie
vous savez quand on traite du dossier de
la sidérurgie on traite pas seulement du
sinn du nord est et de la lorraine
on traite aussi du destin de l'emploi
pour cent cinquante mille personnes
reviendrait tout à l'heure sur le sujet
station de monsieur marché mais les
secteurs prioritaires pour 1977 et bien
et nous sommes à l'heure actuelle en
train d'étudier les conditions
nécessaires pour donner une plus grande
solidité à des secteurs tels que la
sidérurgie la machine-outil les
construction navale le textile les
industries des pâtes et papiers on
oublie cette industrie mais c'est le
deuxième poste déficitaire de notre
commerce extérieur
c'est déjà pas mal est ce que vous êtes
a créé au circuit distribution à
l'égalité sociale
bien sûr il s'agit là de
l'assainissement général de l'économie
française que nous avons entrepris et
qui doit couvrir trois secteurs le
secteur des industries dont la
réorganisation est nécessaire le secteur
des entreprises nationalisées
non pas du tout comme on le dit pour
porter atteinte au principe des
entreprises nationales et à l'honneur
des entreprises nationales mais pour que
leur gestion soit exemplaire comme doit
être la gestion des entreprises
nationales et enfin ce secteur la
sécurité sociale des satanés de cette
année gâchée
les syndicats disent on ne peut pas
discuter avec monsieur raymond barthes
et la ville monsieur michel rolland par
exemple la cfdt et monsieur bergeron
vous recommande en quelque sorte de ne
pas faire preuve d'un entêtement
excessif et il demandait ici même que
vous preniez en quelque sorte un nouvel
engagement de maintenir développer la
politique contractuelle est ce que vous
pouvez faire trois remarques brèves sur
ce que vous pouvez me dire premièrement
on ne peut pas dire que je ne dialogue
pas j'ai toujours cherché à dialoguer on
m'a répondu
soit par la critique systématique soit
par des défilés de porteurs de pancartes
deuxième observation mon entêtement
ce n'est pas de l'entêtement monsieur
elkabbach le 22 septembre dernier en
expliquant aux françaises et aux
français
le programme de redressement économique
et financier j'ai dit que l'effort
serait long et continue et que nous
devrions le maintenir tout au long de
ce qui inspire le gouvernement c'est
l'intérêt du pays
troisième observation j'ai entendu
monsieur bergeron me lancer à travers 20
appels sur la politique contractuelle
il sait très bien quelle est ma position
là dessus et je la confirme
d'abord je suis attaché politique
contractuelle
la preuve en est qu'en septembre dernier
je n'ai touché à aucun à des contrats
signés ils se sont exécutés normalement
deuxième preuve de mon attachement à la
politique contractuelle
c'est que des négociations se sont
ouvertes pour examiner de nouveau
contrat de progrès dans les entreprises
nationales et dans la fonction publique
votre porte n'est pas fermée aux
syndicats maintenant mais elle a
toujours été ouverte et vous savez je
reçois les 5000 cas et je voudrais
revenir à la politique contractuelle ce
qui est important ce n'est pas de dire
la politique contractuelle
c'est de dire qu'il faut faire une
politique contractuelle qui soit
compatible avec les exigences générales
de l'économie française c'est ce que
nous nous efforçons de feu un aspect qui
est un peu moindre impôt faux à travers
les questions
seul un caractère un peu politique même
si vous n'aimez pas ça monsieur marché
vous a attaqué hier avec une certaine
violence si vous permettez je le cite le
plan barre c'est une catastrophe c'est
inquiète le montrent les travailleurs
sont auteurs puis à pleines mains dans
les caisses de l'état il dilapide épiler
deniers publics il est même trop
prétentieuse que lui reste indifférent
je suis inquiet pour monsieur marché
j'ai le sentiment qu'il ne se contrôle
plus
on n'aimait pas la politique
politicienne il faut que je vous parle
de la majorité si vous permettez
monsieur premier ministre toujours avec
une citation celle de monsieur chirac
qui disait hier au cours de son premier
meeting parisien participantes à un
gouvernement que nous soutenons nous
sommes en droit d'exiger la neutralité
de son chef et de ses ministres qu'un
premier ministre peut et doit être
neutre monsieur chirac et le président
d'une formation politique qui soutient
le gouvernement
mais le président d'aucune formation
politique comme aucune formation
politique n'a le droit d'exiger quelque
chose du gouvernement et du premier
ministre
nous ne sommes pas sous la quatrième
république nous sommes sous la vème
république
vous êtes neutre n'êtes pas neutre
presque un premier ministre les s'agit
pas de savoir s'ils ont des notes ou si
l'on n'est pas neutre la position du
gouvernement est très clair pour le
président edgar faure il le disait à tf1
hier soir vous n'avez pas être
l'animateur de la majorité
monsieur michel poniatowski disait ici
vous êtes le chef de la majorité et son
animateur leur pouvoir clair quel sera
votre rôle politique le premier ministre
dans les prochains mois et en
particulier jusqu'aux législatives
j'ai un grand respect pour monsieur
edgar faure et je sais bien que je ne
suis pas capable de rivaliser avec lui
en ce qui concerne la subtilité de
l'homme politique
mais ceci dit ce n'est pas monsieur
edgar faure qui désigne le premier
ministre des guides et termine les
attributions du premier ministre le
président de la république m'a confiées
selon la tradition la vème république la
charge le moment venu de conduire la
campagne et je peux vous dire que si je
suis toujours premier ministre je
m'acquitte ray est de cette charge
je voudrais ajouter un mot sur ce coin
vous parliez tout à l'heure des
élections municipales et de neutralité
les élections municipales ne sont pas
telles qu'elles doivent
visés outre mesure l'attention du
premier ministre les membres du
gouvernement encore que ceux ci sont
souvent candidats et doivent participer
à la campagne et en ce qui concerne les
élections législatives
il s'agira d'un tournant car il s'agira
pour les français d'un choix de société
alors je tiens à vous dire que ce jour
là que je sois premier ministre que je
ne sois pas premier ministre
je serai présent et si mes compatriotes
m'accorde quelques crises
je mettrai ce crédit au service des
institutions de la vème république au
service du président de la république
est au service d'un combat pour une
société de liberté de progrès et de
justice vous le ferez avec autant de
fermeté d'énergie que vous occupez les
affaires économiques
on jugera dernière question vous disiez
en octobre de l'année dernière
dans un premier temps l'impopularité
fatale aujourd'hui vous devenez
populaire est ce qu'on s'y habitue gains
je suis alkama je me suis jamais laissé
déconcerté par certains sondages et je
ne tomberai pas aujourd'hui dans la
griserie que peuvent entraîner d'autres
sondages
j'ai de lourdes responsabilités que m'a
confié le président de la république je
les assume et je n'ai qu'un souhait et
c'est ce qui me réconforte en constatant
l'évolution actuelle c'est que les
françaises et français se rendent compte
que je ne suis animé que d'un seul souci
celui de traiter les affaires de la
france et de le faire dans le sens de
l'intérêt général pour mr
vous allez peut-être déjà aperçu la
campagne électorale est officiellement
ouverte
les affiches électorales vont pouvoir
décorer les murs ce ne sera pas toujours
du goût des écologistes de bonne heure
ce matin
en tout cas à paris les supporteurs des
différents candidats se bousculaient
devant les bureaux de vote pour arracher
l'adversaire le meilleur panneaux
réglementaires
le numéro 1 celui qui est placé le plus
près de la porte d'entrée pour cela il
faut être parfois sportif la guerre des
chaluts aura-t-elle lieu
depuis quelques semaines les pays du
marché commun de l'europe et donc la
france ont étendu leur zone de pêche à
200 milles au large des côtes 200 milles
cela veut dire que désormais aucun
bateau étranger ne pourra venir pêcher à
moins de 370 km du littoral cept
décision prise à la conférence des
nations unies sur le droit de la mer
pose bien sûr un problème de
surveillance elle provoque aussi des
incidents la france vient donc de
décider l'extension à 200 milles marins
de sa zone économique protégée autour de
l'hexagone décision prise en accord avec
les pays membres du marché commun mais
déjà cela crée un certain nombre de
problèmes notamment avec les
britanniques par exemple dans les ports
bretons actuellement c'est la grogne
pour nous ce sera ce sera une mauvaise
affaire sûrement pourquoi donc ça veut
dire nous sommes spécialement conçus
copé celle en hausse in i la langoustine
se trouve dans une zone inférieure à 200
mais il se trouve près des côtes
françaises par des côtes anglaises près
des codes de irlandaise et anglais et
les irlandais les anglais vous font des
difficultés il ne s'arrête en pêche et
on vire le chalut et contre le maillage
des garde côtes britanniques britannique
oui parce qu'elle semblait nous
demandent 50 villes a fait une
catastrophe pour nous à 50 milles
autre câble ce que nous travaillons déjà
entre 6 et 12 me en plus c'est ya plus
de pêcheurs est un peu chez ailleurs
bien plus loin que ils ont à domicile
est vidé de son biseau si je ne fais
plus rien donc c'est 200 milles vous
êtes contre quatre enfants tonnes contre
pour les russes n est pas pour nous
en fait une mère européenne commune au
club des neuf c'est bien à condition que
tout le monde les pays membres puisque y
pêcher librement les britanniques ne
sont pas de cet avis ils disent à bon
droit
nous avons les eaux les plus
poissonneuses nous ne voulons pas nous
laisser piller et il refuse de partager
leurs zones à plus de 158 la france elle
n'est pas d'accord et elle demande le
respect intégral de la règle communauté
en france est ancestrale conditionnel
que nos pêcheurs ont pris l'habitude
depuis longtemps d'aller pêcher loin de
leurs côtes et clio pêche
partant de là près des codes de bi
communautaire comme l'angleterre comme
l'irlande
dès lors toutes les restrictions
apportées avancions de mer communautaire
pénaliserait lourdement nos pêcheurs du
chalutier qui pourra pas être réparé
cette semaine quelque part au dessus de
l'atlantique entre la bretagne le golfe
de gascogne
un avion militaire français en
patrouille dénombre moins de 6 heures
une douzaine de chalutiers soviétique
dans no 209 dans quelques semaines ils
ne pourront plus y venir car malgré
leurs dissensions internes les pays du
marché commun ont fait bloc cette fois
ci les russes qui ne reconnaissait pas
les neuf ont dû venir négocier à
bruxelles un accord a été conclu qui
limitera leurs activités en échange les
navires communautaires pourront aller
pêcher dans les eaux russes
nous allons donc
dans quelques jours il y voir beaucoup
plus clair et pouvoir mieux maîtrisé
l'exercice de la pêche des étrangers
dans les eaux françaises
alors pour le moment qu'est ce qu'on
fait on les laisse faire il ne s'agit
pas de dramatiser mais simplement de
progressivement montré notre volonté de
faire respecter les décisions
communautaires dans les eaux
communautaires dans la lutte acharnée
que se livrent les états pour la
possession des maires il ya également le
partage et la délimitation des zones
connues
quand par exemple les côtes de deux pays
sont mitoyennes ou à une distance
inférieure à 400 milles généralement on
négocie dans le cas contraire on plaide
c'est ainsi que nous sommes en procès
avec nos voisins britanniques
encore heureux objet du litige la
possession d'une zone au large
d'ouessant
quel est l'intérêt de cette zone un
débat et bien les travaux que nous avons
réalisés nous mêmes en sismique montrent
qu'il ya des accumulations sédimentaires
importante
or habituellement lorsque l'on parle
bassin sédimentaire
on pense à pétrole parmi les ressources
il explorait de la mer il ya également
ceux ci c'est un module polymétallique
ça ressemble en gros un boulet de
charbon les métaux manganèse nickel
cuivre et cobalt des métaux qui sont
rares qui sont chers et dont le fond de
la mer est littéralement tapissé ces
métaux entre est il besoin de le dire
dans la composition des produits des
industries de pointe telles que
l'aéronautique les fusées et
l'électronique autant dire que les
grandes puissances se livrent dès
maintenant à une course effrénée pour
savoir qui d'entre elles la première va
exploiter cette ressource se partager le
gâteau 11 millions de kilomètres carrés
voilà la superficie maritime de la
france si elle décidé d'étendre sa zone
protégée aux départements et territoires
d'outre-mer
ce serait un atout de plus dans la
bataille que se livrent les grandes
puissances pour la conquête du pétrole
il est jeune 38 ans certains le trouvent
séduisant et il est ministre
david owen le nouveau chef de la
diplomatie britannique est de passage à
paris où il doit rencontrer en ce moment
même d'ailleurs monsieur louis ii guy
ringot david owen pourrait prendre
contact également à paris avec des
personnalités de l'opposition comme de
la majorité
ça se fait beaucoup en angleterre amin
dada et créa jimmy carter pour lui
donner les conseils oui oui pour lui
donner des conseils
le maréchal président de l'ouganda ferme
les frontières de son pays ou deux cents
américains qui résident et il les tient
presque ce soir en otage un mine dada
n'aime pas que l'on regarde ce qui se
passe chez lui et il refuse de recevoir
la mission d' enquête des nations unies
sur la mort plutôt troublante d'un
archevêque anglican amin dada se croit
victime d'un complot sioniste et il
exhorte son armée le président ougandais
ce fait ne fait plus sourire aujourd'hui
il inquiète avec sa terreur il était une
fois
il y a 6 ans un nouveau chef d'état en
ouganda un petit pays d'afrique coincé
entre le kenya et le zaïre amin dada à
l'époque le nom n'avait même pas fait
sourire
commençait alors dans l'ombre les
résistible ascension du boxeur sergent
très vite promu par lui-même général et
bientôt maréchal mais aujourd'hui on ne
compte plus les massacres perpétrés sur
ordre personnel du maréchal massacre
contre son peuple
des ingénieurs italiens ont vu les
centaines de cadavres flottaient près du
seul barrage du pays massacre aussi
contre la colonie indienne
dernier en date le très mystérieux
accident mortel de l'archevêque anglican
et de deux ministres du gouvernement
l'ouganda fait partie de la nuit et le
maréchal amin dada et président de
l'organisation de l'unité africaine
mais quel chef d'état africain peut
raisonnablement être représentés par lui
les facéties sanglant du maréchal ont
poussé le président carter a affirmé que
les événements d'ouganda écoeuré le
monde civilisé
il y a 6 ans on pouvait croire que le
maréchal incarner la revanche d'une
afrique longtemps humilié mais celui qui
pouvait représenter un espoir et un
exemple s'est transformé très vite en
dictateur aujourd'hui le monde et
surtout l'afrique ne doivent-ils pas
partager le deuil de l'ouganda mais
c'est une question que nous allons poser
nous avons en direct avec jean claude
mongeau quelque part à paris le
président du gabon monsieur bongo
bonsoir monsieur bongo et merci est-ce
que vous vous sentez vous représentez
par le président amin dada au cri de
mort puisque d'abord je m'appelle bongo
je m'appelle pas miner d'une part et
d'autre part et jeu se présente d'abord
neige et nord de l'ouganda donc un trade
jan innés moi il ya deux personnalités
bien différentes les des menaces 16 ce
qui se passe en ouganda
ah bon est ce que cela veut dire que
vous vous désintéresser de ce que de ce
qui se passe en ouganda nullement je me
désintéresse pas de ce qui se passe à
nos banda
est il que je dois d'abord être informé
de ce qui s'est passé au canada
je l'aï appris par la voie de la paix ce
et vos collègues tout à l'air mon presse
de la même question à eau sortie de
l'elysée que ce que je pensais
sur les événements de l'ouganda ben
j'aurais préféré franchement que vous
maîtrisez exactement qu'est ce qui se
passe là-bas et qu'attendez vous de moi
par exemple monsieur le président bongo
des menaces pèsent ce soir sur la
colonie américaine d'ouganda pourtant
l'hospitalité est une vertu africaine je
suis franchois d'accord avec vous je
pense que en ce qui me concerne
personnellement en tant que responsable
d'abonnés nous sommes
dejean des dialogues et c'est pourquoi
dans la dévise même de notre parti nous
avons inscrit dialogue tolérance et paix
mais est ce que vous comprenez ce qui
est en train de se passer monsieur bongo
en ouganda en tant qu'africain et je
comprends parfaitement mais l'ouganda
est un pays indépendant et souverain e
mois
respectueux de la souveraineté de chaque
pays je ne peux pas me mettre à la place
de le du président de notre dame en tant
qu'africain comme vous le dites je n'ai
qu'une seule inquiétude ce que vous les
occidentaux vous croyez que tous les
africains sont pareils donc en tant que
responsable africain moi je ne peux que
demander diamin franchement elle voit sa
position parce qu'au départ on nous a
parlé comme vous le disais tout à
l'heure d'un simple accident de voiture
léthel n'y croyez pas vous même je dis
c'est que j'ai lu et je n'ai pas vu j'ai
toujours veulent simplement et je me dis
que ce que je vois
bon on a dit que c'était un simple
accident d'auto après lesquels on a dit
c'était un complot ourdi contre la
personne du président de l'ouganda et de
son gouvernement alors un parti de là
c'est d'enchaîner d'autres problèmes
avant c'était le britannique aujourd'hui
ce sont les américains pour comprendre
dès que je me trouve dans zénith et
d'embarras au collège je ne peux pas
vraiment tu dis c'est que c'est la pause
je peux ajouter si vous permettez le
président bongo que finalement depuis
deux ans à l'organisation de l'unité
africaine vous être présenté en tant
qu'africain par le président dada et je
prends pas les rituels à l'heure où je
vous parle il n'est plus président
delouya vous faites là une petite le
présent de l'eau y est toujours un lieu
pour m
c'était facile au moment où nous parlons
précisément c'est le premier ministre de
l'île maurice ganay le présent exercice
enfin ce qui intéresse peut-être les
européens les occidentaux c'est ma
dernière question
c'est cette inquiétude sur le sort des
américains sur le régime de terreur qui
est que fait régner le président amin
dada sur la crainte que l'occident voit
l'afrique à travers ce qui se passe dans
ce pays
avec ce dirigeant je crois que je suis
je partage la même inquiétude du gouf
mais il faut pas seulement dit l'afrique
hier je vu à travers votre petit écran
quelqu'un qui lui ce qui parle aussi de
ce qui se passe en russie
je crois que la dèche il faut pas
seulement parler de l'afrique et de
l'occident il faut parler des pays d'une
manière nominatif allait à laquelle nous
parlait de l'ouganda et moi je suis
d'accord avec vous pour déplorer
franchement ce qui se passe en ouganda
car je crois qu'il n'y a pas de problème
que l'homme puisse pas trouver une
solution la solution c'est le dialogue
et lorsqu'on refuse le dialogue eh ben
je crois que là on ne peut pas trouver
une solution et puis aussi il faut
savoir que le chef d'état africain il
faut voir comment ils sont arrivés au
pouvoir il y en a qui ont été élus
démocratiquement et universel ma part là
il y en a qui sont venus par
la violence physique la violence oui eh
ben c'est là aussi margueron pas la
violence monsieur le président merci
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce journal
d'antenne 2 est sans doute à bientôt
pour terminer je voudrais dire que
décidément le sport français donnent
quelques espoirs et satisfaction en ce
moment après les footballeur mercredi
les basketteuses de clermont ferrand
bien failli réaliser un exploit hier
soir devant les soviétiques de riga
elles ont été battues bien sûr mais de
quatre points seulement
il est vrai qu'elle ne pouvait pas faire
grand chose devant l'éternel géante
semenova la météo elisabeth est bien
pour demain mêmes pour tout le week end
la météo n'est pas très optimiste
puisqu'elle prévoit encore un peu de
pluie
demain c'est le nord et le nord-est qui
seront les plus touchés ailleurs
beaucoup de brouillard et des nuages
avec tout de même l'après midi quelques
belles éclaircies
par endroits il neigera sur les vosges
sur le jura et sur le nord du massif
central au dessus de 800 mètres et
dimanche et bien il y aura un peu de
pluie sur toute la moitié ouest de la
france et les températures seront en
baisse
les nouvelles d'hervé claude vers 23
heures demain et dimanche
j'entendis demain samedi et demi avec
jean claude mongeau
nous nous retrouverons lundi je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée merci
d'être resté avec nous fidèlement
bonsoir